la leyenda comienza con un oficial
francés del ejército de napoleón en la
guerra franco-prusiana del siglo 19 el
oficial más condecorado del ejército de
napoleón bonaparte
el emperador tenía que entregar un
mensaje de suma importancia tras líneas
enemigas y fue así como montando a su
caballo cabalgó durante horas
eventualmente se topó con el enemigo y
tuvo que defender su vida con pistolas y
espadas salió victorioso aunque
lamentablemente su corcel terminó herido
decidido a entregar el mensaje el
oficial siguió este camino con el único
recurso que le quedaba mano su propio
cuerpo y fue así que sin armas sin
caballo se vio obligado a correr tan
rápido como sus piernas y su respiración
se lo permitiera antes de llegar a su
destino un río se atravesó en su camino
tuvo que cruzar los nadando y ya al
llegar al otro lado
al final entregó el mensaje
según cuenta la leyenda cuando llegó
incluso el oficial a cargo le preguntó y
se puede saber a qué se debe semejante
demora si tan solo supiera
y fue así que el padre de los juegos
olímpicos modernos del barón pierre de
coubertín rescata esa leyenda y decide
crear un deporte que emular a las
virtudes necesarias para el militar
perfecto natación tiro esgrima
equitación y atletismo los combino en un
solo deporte siendo las olimpiadas de
1912 aquellas en las cuales el pentatlón
moderno hiciera su debut de manera
oficial
soy ismael hernández medallista olímpico
de bronce los pasados juegos de río de
janeiro 2016 uno de los 103 medallistas
olímpicos que tienen méxico
al igual que en la leyenda
tuve que enfrentarme a muchos obstáculos
para cruzar esa meta el 20 de agosto del
2016 un segundo fue la diferencia entre
la medalla de bronce y el quinto lugar
si nos vamos a los reinos de la
velocidad a los 100 metros planos por
ejemplo esa diferencia entre el primero
y el octavo lugar son de 25 milésimas de
segundo
la real academia española de la lengua
define el segundo como un periodo de
tiempo muy breve una de las 60 partes
iguales que divide un minuto para mí los
segundos son todos son una diferencia un
segundo o la milésima parte de uno tiene
el potencial de cambiar tu vida y para
alcanzar una medalla olímpica hay que
entrenar millones de segundos
de eso de eso quiero hablarles hoy de
los más de 100 millones de segundos que
me llevaron hasta esta tarde del 20 de
agosto en brasil y que me trajeron hasta
aquí para decirles que un día tiene 86
mil 400 segundos y desde que empecé a
hablar han transcurrido casi 180 de
ellos
si les cuesta dimensionar 100 millones
de segundos les platico 100 millones de
segundos es el equivalente a 3.2 años si
los 24 horas los 7 días de la semana se
los hubieran pasado en una alberca una
pista de atletismo un stand de tiro una
sala de esgrima o montando un caballo
esos 100 millones de segundos los he
dividido en cinco diferentes tipos en mi
caso primero vinieron los segundos de
descubrimiento
llegué al pentatlón moderno cuando era
un niño tenía 9 años tenía la
imaginación muy inquieta amaba las
historias de los tres mosqueteros de
alejandro dumas y la verdad es que era
muy poco hábil para otros deportes
vivíamos en una unidad militar ya que mi
madre se desempeñaba como médico del
ejército por azares del destino un día
me encontré un grupo de niños y los vi
correr y nadar me acerqué al entrenador
intrigado y le pregunté oiga qué hacen
aquí el entrenador me dijo nosotros les
enseñamos cómo correr cómo nadar pero
también les enseñamos cómo tirar con
pistola cómo pelear con espadas y cómo
montar caballos y honestamente qué niña
no queda enganchado en un deporte
después escuchar de pistolas espadas y
caballos en una misma oración
inmediatamente quedé enganchado y
durante lo que serán tal vez mis
primeros diez millones de segundos me
dediqué a entrenar pensando lo divertido
que sería algún día convertirme en el
heredero de d'artagnan y aprender a
batir me en duelos como los mosqueteros
de alejandro dumas
fue cuestión de segundos que encontrar a
este grupo de niños cuestión de segundos
que me enganchara para entrenar
pentatlón moderno y fueron esos segundos
los que me enseñaron una de las
lecciones más importantes hasta el día
de hoy por más fuera de lo común que
parezca una oportunidad un deporte una
decisión una acción siempre debemos
animarnos a descubrir a veces incluso
dentro de nosotros mismos y aproximarnos
con la mente abierta algo que en
segundos puede que nos cambie la vida
cuántas veces no nos arriesgamos por
vergüenza por comodidad por miedo por
falta de información y en cuestión de
segundos tal vez ya hayamos perdido la
oportunidad de descubrir algo nuevo
pero bueno aún falta más allá de sólo el
descubrimiento y aquí es cuando vienen
los segundos tipos de segundos los
segundos de aprendizaje aproximadamente
36 millones de segundos de pura
paciencia después de descubrir mi pasión
por el pentatlón llegó el momento de
aprender el resto de las disciplinas
empecé por incorporar el tiro a mi
rutina de natación y carrera y al igual
que en su momento de la natación un
mentir o se convirtió en mi talón de
aquiles gracias a entrenamientos extras
a escuchar a mis entrenadores y a mucha
paciencia fue como poco a poco empecé a
mejorar el mismo patrón se repitió en
esgrima al principio llegué con la idea
de que esgrima esgrima sería bastante
fácil total cuantos actores no habíamos
visto todos nosotros peleando con
espadas en películas y en la tele no
podría ser tan difícil verdad un
entrenador alguna vez me dijo que la
esgrima era como ajedrez en movimiento
un deporte de estrategia y explosividad
y a mi corta edad me creí el paralelismo
lo que mi entrenador no me había dicho
es que
a diferencia de las jugadas éstas
pasaban en milésimas de segundo y un
movimiento en falso podía terminar en
una estocada bastante dolorosa
pero bueno seguía entrenando millones de
segundos después mejore
y eventualmente llegué a la equitación
la equitación también me todos mis
millones de segundos solo que aparte de
esos segundos me enseñó a saber cómo
caer literal y figurativamente hablando
con cada nueva disciplina conforme más
tiempo le dedicaba al deporte pasa de
ser un atleta de media tabla a estar en
los podios nacionales a representar a
méxico en competencias internacionales
el esfuerzo y los resultados positivos
solo me motivan a seguir entrenando pero
esto evidentemente me costó años horas
segundos de dedicación de dolor de
frustración de fracasos algo a veces
difícil de entender en una generación
que vive en la inmediatez pues cuando no
hay resultados viene la desmotivación el
rechazo la renuncia y es en esos
momentos cuando tenemos que recordar
porque empezamos algo aceptar que nos va
a tomar tiempo llegar a esos resultados
y ojalá no sean 36 millones de segundos
al final lo que sí es un hecho es que
hay una correlación entre el tiempo que
le dedicamos una actividad y lo mejor en
los resultados
después de estos segundos vienen los
segundos de decisión aproximadamente
800.000 segundos cortos cruciales porque
qué pasa cuando creemos haber encontrado
las respuestas de nuestra vida pero la
vida decide cambiarnos las preguntas qué
pasa cuando cuando nuestras metas
cambian qué pasa cuando los seguimos
intentando pero nuestro talento no es
suficiente para lo que queremos lograr
qué pasa si nos equivocamos
qué pasa si simplemente un día nos
levantamos y decimos queremos algo
diferente es completamente válido
tenemos segundos para decidir seguir
adelante cambiar de estrategia o del
plan o cambiar la meta toda la familia
del lado de mi mamá es médico
lógicamente la inercia familiar me llevo
a interesarme por la medicina pero
escoger esta profesión me significaba
renunciar al pentatlón por la inversión
de tiempo que pedirían ambas disciplinas
así que opté por algo que me interesará
y que no me impidiera seguir entrenando
me gustaba leer me gustaban las
matemáticas me gustaba la historia hoy
soy economista
en mi carrera deportiva pasó algo
similar en el 2008 mientras veía la
inauguración de los juegos olímpicos de
beijing la cámara enfocó a óscar soto
amigo mío pentatleta que había estudiado
en el tec de monterrey
la idea me tomó por sorpresa si él
estaba ahí es porque era posible
estudiar e ir a unos suelos olímpicos
eso es lo que tenía que hacer
lógicamente fue cuestión de segundos
me tomaría muchos muchos segundos
millones de segundos prepararme para una
competencia de esa talla lo que no sabía
sería que dos años después en el 2010 me
encontraré en un aeropuerto en budapest
a punto de abordar mi vuelo hacia en
méxico cuando recibí una llamada en la
cual me informaban que junto con varios
mexicanos seríamos sancionados por haber
resultado positivo en una prueba
antidopaje
una extensión de doping es las peores
cosas que le puede suceder a un
deportista es una marca de por vida en
tu expediente como atleta
y las consecuencias son terribles
en mi caso se trataba de clembuterol un
anabólico que se utiliza mucho en
américa latina para lograr que el ganado
de consumo tenga más carne menos grasa y
crezca más rápido mismas razones por las
cuales es una substancia prohibida
dentro de la lista de la asociación
mundial antidopaje sin embargo es es una
substancia presente en casi toda la
carne que consumimos y me atrevería a
decir que no todos tenemos pleno
conocimiento de ingerirla
recuerdo que mi corazón se tuvo
recuerdo que el miedo me invadió de pies
a cabeza recuerdo que el calor escalo
por mi espalda cada palabra taladraba a
un agujero en mi estómago no entendía
nada era tal mi desconsuelo que perdió
el control del número de lágrimas que
había derramado
para colmo aún me faltaban 13 horas de
vuelo si mis padres y mi teléfono sin
poder hacer nada más que estar sentado y
seguir llorando
al llegar al aeropuerto de la ciudad de
mexico tomé mis cosas no me despedí de
mi equipo ni de mi entrenador me salí
como intentando huir de repente me voy
con mi papá en la puerta de entradas
internacionales me agarro entre sus
brazos
tranquilo tranquilo todo va a estar bien
y le creí seguimos adelante enfrentamos
los medios de comunicación aceptamos la
sanción no teníamos otra opción todo el
tiempo que habíamos invertido en
entrenar en prepararnos sentía que había
sido un desperdicio pero estaba
equivocado estos segundos son los que en
verdad retan la firmeza de nuestros
anhelos de nuestras decisiones no tengan
miedo de tomarse tiempo para pensar
sobre su futuro meditar sobre sus
errores sus aciertos y recuerden la
decisión sobre cómo reaccionar a una
situación siempre está en nuestras manos
después llegan los segundos de fracaso
aproximadamente 500 mil segundos incluyó
dentro de estos segundos en mi mejor
limitada recolección el tiempo después
de una caída o de algún accidente del
cual estuve convaleciente el tiempo
durante el cual estuve lesionado o
incluso el tiempo en el cual me
cuestioné fuertemente en mi carrera
deportiva o en seguir adelante después
de un resultado negativo
estos segundos son muy peligrosos no por
las consecuencias directas o físicas
sino por el impacto negativo que pueden
tener en nuestra seguridad y en nuestra
mente si no lo estamos con la seriedad
necesaria y con la cabeza fría en mi
caso el mundial de roma en el 2012
cuando me tocaba montar un caballo es
sumamente complicado que minutos antes
había tirado a otro competidor esta
competencia lo único que me separaba del
boleto olímpico de londres-2012 pero en
un arranque de soberbia y arrogancia me
creí superior al jinete anterior
esta vez fue el caballo el que me
demostró lo equivocado que estaba el
resultado 5 fracturas en el rostro y un
diente menos bastaron 5 segundos de
soberbia para cambiar la imagen perfecta
de salir de la arena con los brazos en
alto celebrando la clasificación a los
juegos olímpicos en su lugar ahora
abandonaba la arena a bordo de una
camilla sobre una ambulancia en camino
al hospital más cercano en cuestión de
segundos puse en riesgo mi vida mis
sueños mi trabajo y mi esfuerzo
la soberbia fue igual de poderosa y
destructiva que la inercia de salir
catapultado del asiento del caballo
muchos pensarían que los momentos más
dolorosos fueron aquellos en las cuales
me distante contra el obstáculo les
puedo asegurar que lo más doloroso vino
después cuando todas las lesiones las
fracturas cuando todos los moretones
tuvieron sanado después cuando todo por
lo que había trabajado en mi vida se
llenó de inseguridades de miedos
estaba poniendo en riesgo mi vida en
verdad estaba dispuesto a subirme en un
caballo vamos
había sido afortunado en verdad quería
seguir haciéndolo yo creo que mejor no
mejor
mejor renunciamos no
y aquí fue cuando todos los segundos de
repente hicieron clic se conectaron en
que encajaron en la vida siempre habrá
situaciones que por una u otra razón no
salen como lo planeamos y debemos de ser
lo suficientemente humildes para
identificar nuestros errores
reconocerlos y si depende de nosotros
saber qué podemos hacer para mejorarlos
para corregirlos recordar que el fracaso
a veces es puro aprendizaje disfrutado
de momentos difíciles ayuda a hacerle
frente a estos segundos sumamente
incómodos
finalmente llegan los segundos de
excelencia 28 mil 799 segundos sin lugar
a dudas los segundos más difíciles de
conseguir son el resultado de todos los
demás en mi caso ese es el número de
segundos exactos de mi competencia de
río de janeiro el 20 de agosto es el
número de segundos más cortos resultado
del esfuerzo de toda una vida para mí
esto fue una esgrima bien planeada y
bien estructurada usando una estrategia
como el mismísimo d'artagnan una
natación contundente y rápida una
confianza y humildad plena sobre el
caballo un tiro del cual robin hood se
hubiera sentido orgulloso una carrera
tan rápida como aquella del oficial
francés de las leyendas
vamos
tantos segundos invertidos para que el
día en que una nueva situación
inesperada se nos cruzara nos impidiera
cruzar la meta este 20 de agosto no fue
perfecto mi espada se descompuso mi
pistola se rompió mis agujetas vamos de
desarrollar en la última vuelta no
importo el resto de los 100 millones de
segundos estaban ahí para ayudarme para
no rendirme los segundos de excelencia
son aquellos donde nuestros sueños se
materializan en donde las medallas se
cuelgan en donde los premios se entregan
en donde pasamos a la historia son
segundos para los cuales nos preparamos
todo una vida segundos de inspiración
segundos de reflexión de celebración de
reconocimiento por nuestros logros por
nuestros errores pero más importante de
reconocimiento a la gente que siempre
estuvo ahí presente para apoyarnos en el
camino
si en lugar de 28 mil 799 segundos
hubieran sido 28 mil 800 hoy estaría
contándoles esa historia desde la
perspectiva de un quinto lugar y no por
eso sería diferente lo que les estoy
diciendo hoy al final el éxito no se
mide solo en segundos tienen como
vivimos cada día para alcanzar es la
suma de esfuerzo descubrimiento
aprendizaje decisiones fracasos y
momentos de excelencia que hacen de
nuestra vida una experiencia única y
gratificante
y ustedes
qué están haciendo con sus segundos